voting for a new parliament that's
underway in senegal opposition parties
are hoping to win enough seats to stop
president mahi sal from holding a
majority they want to block saul from
seeking a third term which is barred
under the constitution senegal is one of
africa's more stable democracies but
there were violent protests in the
run-up to the vote
some voters say they hope the next
assembly will do more
i'm hoping for change from the way our
national assembly has worked up until
now
we hope that with this new legislature
we have representatives who will take
into account the concerns of ordinary
people
we realize that our vote is a choice for
who we want in the national assembly as
a sort of balance of power
journalist maria nicolescu is in the
senegalese capital dakar i put it to her
that the main issue in this
parliamentary vote appears to be the
presidential election two years from now
yes well these elections will certainly
be an interesting milestone ahead of the
presidential election of 2024 which has
already
caused some controversy the opposition
is trying to make these
a show of strength and put pressure on
president mackie sal
critics have accused him of wanting to
run for a third term in 2024 despite
the country's two-term limit the
president himself has been very vague on
this topic but if the opposition manages
to gain a majority out of the 165
parliamentary seats then it hopes that
it will put an end to makisol's
potential ambitions for a third term but
it also hopes to force the government to
cohabitate with uh the opposition
coalitions yawi as can we and walu
senegal who have joined forces in the
hope
to reach this majority uh an opposition
breakthrough in parliament could also
mean that makisel will appoint a prime
minister from the opposition what their
chances are is unclear so far especially
in the rural areas but it could be a
tight run in 2019 the main opposition
leader usman sunku arrived third in the
presidential election and most recently
in january the opposition won major
cities such as dhaka and siegelshock in
local elections
maria senegal has uh been seen as one of
africa's more stable democracies how
much worry is there that this could all
be changing
well yes senegal has
a good reputation of being among among
the stabler countries politically in
africa but especially in west africa it
has a good track record of democratic
processes as well as relatively good
press freedom and freedom
of expression time and again there have
been
political tensions for example in march
2021
several violent protests erupted after
us manson was accused of rape and more
recently in june one protest in support
of the opposition
turned violent with three people killed
and several injured this came after the
constitutional court invalidated the
list of national candidates for year we
ask and we forcing the party to run with
the list of alternates only the
opposition accused the government of um
of purposely
trying to to block the opposition which
the government has denied but things
have calmed down in july with a with a
campaign month that unfolded peacefully
uh senegalese the senegalese population
is expressing increasing frustrations so
things could blow up again for example
if nikesaw decides to run for a third
term but for now you know things are
calm here in dakar and according to what
we know in the rest of the country as
well
you